we'll take a bunch of suggestions let's
come to you guys first what you want to
hear a rap about juicy spam as it so
presumably not the food you mean they're
the emails but food is a banned
suggestion as I that'sa I'm gonna I'm
gonna say that spam is inedible so
therefore we will accept it spam great
you guys what you want rockbell
masterpiece theater
so obviously I'm British we didn't have
that is that that's the radio that they
do radio plays it was TV was it all sand
wells involved it's still on so they do
plays on TV every Sunday night thank you
very much I I will make sure to I mean I
don't even own a TV
okay masterpiece theater spam get back
in the room what you wanna rap about
space travel let's be more specific
let's so let's kind of dove and you
can't say anything do with the moon
because that's too obvious cuz that's
happened pretty recently so something
else do a space travel back to the
future that's not space travel
that's literally time travel which is
the opposite of space it's a separate
dimension there's three dimensions of
space it forward emerges time never the
twain shall meet
so know what space travel van I was
asking you how about rocket to Uranus
yeah yeah I'm glad we waited for that
I was worth it this target that's your
favorite joke so far is now I got that
one spam a rocket to Uranus cool it must
be said you guys over here what do I
rock that cellular respiration now
obviously I know what that means for but
for the benefit of him
so respiration people think is breathing
but it's not it's the kind of conversion
of oxygen to ATP's that right yeah so
check it out mister biology down here
great over here just very upset people
just like oh no cellular respiration
masterpiece theater a rocket to Uranus
and spam one final one pinatas yeah I'll
tell you that was that inspired by the
that news story from a couple of weeks
ago about the do you see that it was
very funny and they made a pinata in the
shape of ice agents and then small
Mexican children were beaten there with
baseball bats it was really fun it was
really funny obviously as an immigrant
in this country who technically doesn't
have a visa to do this gig now I do I do
in case I was gonna share that online
I've fees it up right listen this is
gonna be a freestyle rap that's a rap
made up on the spot isn't telling those
suggestions it won't be performed again
it's not prepared it's not rehearsed and
we bought all that stuff and don't worry
it won't be bad if we can play that beat
please let's show them how we do this
you can crank it a little bit as well
we'll start with yours I think as well
that sounds pretty fun
wartime stick the food in the can can
alive or kinda ham but technically spam
there's a factory upon the west coast
maybe up Missy alia are often worse that
I've never had to eat it never made room
in my tummy spam the food that I've
never consumed if I saw that in my mom's
kitchen it'd be the opposite of math war
and finger licking cuz it tastes so bad
like a pig's backside where can a slippy
who always wants to slide off the plate
you can chop it up
don't try son apparently is popular with
Monty Python fans they did a song they
were saying spam spam around here I
explore new lands because if you read
spam from front to back
what does it read as cartography maps
moving off the earth out into the
atmosphere of God rocket to Uranus no
need to fear because the nose the cone
has been lubed up we take off taking out
where we move up through the tubes
there's no question not about ingesting
and in your intestine but your way this
is a planet don't be juvenile the only
thing that made this small child man
smile yeah I don't need to bore you I've
got some biological facts for you
cellular respiration situation inside
you if it stops if there's hesitation
then your cells die why because you need
to see it's got the energy
technically ATP I did an a-level and a
GCSE in biology so easily it works like
this let me break it down and say inside
the nucleus you've got the DNA and RNA
of mitochondria they'd be mixing it up
everybody's brain they just like we're
giving up we've no I
if he's right or wrong the tie on the
floor like a fat guy in a thought but
that is okay I'm gonna make it so clear
a sit back Sunday masterpiece theater in
the UK before the ER we say theater you
say theater it's less partial based
beyond belief every sprint ow Aragon is
a masterpiece why would they say that
held in high regard I'll move on under
clothes like Scotland Yard what was the
last word that we needed to do remind me
to check out bring it off yeah I'm gonna
smash it yeah we talked about that here
in Iceland yards with the baseball bat
so many colors made of paper mache with
my Mexican friends at a party I'm
looking for the sweets I'm looking for
the candy the blindfold is off of my
perceptions quite handy I take a stick a
2x4 and hit the little doggy till it
falls to the floor and out comes all the
little lollipops I think about the kids
try and get on when they drop if I take
the blood off and I keep them back and
like if piñas mine so I attack
everybody's my crisps why would you say
that you be small Mexican children far
away it was just a fantasy all cuz it
rhymes
there you go finish freestyle rap
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]